こんにちははじめ社長です実は尾根食べ知ってる人は知ってると思うんですけど結構
マニアックっていうかマイナーの動画を見ますいろんな動画に僕コメントする
ひょっとしたら僕のことを意味わかんない等で見たばできるかもしれません意外と
コメントする c まあいろんな動画みちゃいますなんでみんなが見ないような動画を
たまに見てるんですけどまぁこれはね最高にか
られる道を見つけたあの男の人がでちょっと
法堂数初めて出すどうなのか初投稿なんですけども
コーダーを
コーラをねー
では対ドルでわかるわっはっ
各社も意味ないなコーナーですね花音全部と持ってる人がいたんですよね
ああああああ
これはね感動したような涙が出た
ウソ出せっつっ多かったんですよ話したらコーナー全部の3つの神ですからみぞれ見て
ちょっとマジで全部飲んじゃってて本当に乾燥したんでば9番ねーなーすはマーケて
なんだと思ったわけですよ
こりゃなでまぁその人はタイムを計って中寸前半くらいでこのミニボトルのコーラを
全部飲んでたんですなんで今日は俺もね俺もねまぁ
最強なんで製材最強っていうのはみんなからよく言われても仕方ない仕方ないと思って
僕は自分で前作
欲求のは切ります
20ん
ベリー2
を走ってくださいってなってるぞ
嘘室国は無理なんだけど
いや無理じゃねーその人やったからな
ああそれどうやって話したいんだけどちょっと左だろ
ああああああ
me
膝のいける左側池で本気だします
ん
ああああああ
ああああああああ
ああ
ホラー hood ええっ
ran
よく滑るなもう new たったの時間との酒代じゃない
あっぷっ
ん
貴鬼めっちゃ2位を減ったんですけど全然藍野夢リス右は痛い
なんでだろう
一番ん
いやいや結構のいましたけどね
えっ
そうへい
あねえちょっとあって生命の危機を感じる
奪っ
me
ああああああ
青79だーうよねちょっと額がルーフやて9分38秒で半分くらいかなあんぱん家来は
行けました
誰でまず喫煙なんて根路銘るんじゃのめけどもうのぞと鼻の粘膜が年もダメって言っ
てるあなりたい方今無理です混ぜてちょっと音マネしないで下さいと言いませんよ真似
してもいいけどもう痛いよだからあんな
いやない方が1回やってる人向けだ俺で切り取らないお母さんに行われても俺は知ら
ねえかなぜならいいよ
ん
me
ムーシュー
voodoo
ん